i saw uh desantis today he looks like he
stepped stepped in it here and not in a
good way with getting in the middle of
disney okay he was kind of coming in on
the ted cruz opinion ted cruz said i
think we have a headline here mickey and
pluto
going at it he said
to worries it will show mickey and pluto
going out i mean they're having this
it's wild it's it's wild and and
desantis today said you know when we
were kids we didn't have to worry what
was in cartoons
uh so
i don't know i thought these guys are
crazy and then i look at some of the
movies that disney has coming out they
may
they may be onto something with this
grooming and highly sexualized content
would you like to see some of the movies
that
um
i didn't realize this like uh
bed knobs and nipple clams i did not
know
that that was a disney movie
um the love plug
that
um
who cucked roger rabbit
uh
the little sperm age
[Applause]
honey i transitioned the
kid mary poppers was not
uh
around the world for 80 bucks
and of course the sorcerer's appendage
anyway
that's terrible
you